what are the key elements in being
reasonable so you have to hear both
sides you have to hear the motivations
on both sides
the whys of both sides the stories of
both sides and then like for example
like right now for me okay i'm trying to
identify who's going to be the next ceo
of one of the companies you know two
three four five years from now whatever
the timeline is okay so i have to go
through everybody and i have to process
everybody and have to see the situation
what everybody else is in that guy's
motivation is this this guy's motivation
is that he's got a shorter life span
that one's a little bit scared this
one's fully capable just doesn't want
the responsibility that one wants the
responsibility and wants the job but
he's not capable this so you have to
enter that guy needs a little bit more
to that guy's more about his uh you're
looking at everything and then you sit
there and you say okay
i think this is the best candidate
you're what you're describing is
literally one of my lectures in my
psychology decision making class what
are the types of decision rules that
people use when they're making decisions
in multi-attribute choices you just
describe many attributes motivation
lifespan and so on right so typically
you could do one of two things you could
either look at all of the attributes
weighted by their importance right so
for example if i'm choosing between
different cars if gas efficiency is a
more important attribute to me than
price then i will weigh it differently
i'll put it all together and i'll pick
the card that scores the highest on all
of those attributes but oftentimes
people don't do what you just said pat
what they do is what's called the
lexicographic rule lexicographic rule
means
i only look at my most important
attribute and i choose the alternative
that scores highest on that attribute so
for example if i were choosing between
toothpaste and price is the most
important attribute i'll pick the
toothpaste that has the cheapest price
and that's it so all the other 10
attributes i never looked at that's what
i used by the way as a psychological
mechanism to explain why a lot of people
voted for trump right because even if
hillary clinton when you put all of the
attribute together might have scored
higher than trump many of the population
only looked at a singular attribute
let's suppose i'm an immigration guy i
only care about immigration and if
rightly or wrongly i think that trump
scores better on immigration than
hillary i stop right there i choose
trump i was using that to explain the
psychological mechanisms for why trump
won to sam harris sam harris is a guy
who went completely trump derangement
syndrome right i mean every single
person who voted for trump must have
been a nazi and i said that's what sam
harris said i mean
no i'm not saying said but that's the
position he was sort of advocating uh
sam harris you you tell him any
phenomenon he'll link it to trump you
just got diabetes he's going to explain
to you and by the way he's super
brilliant is it the same sam harris who
debated himself
ben affleck and actually it's it's funny
because i've i've always loved sam i
appreciate him he he's supposed to be a
rational guy a meditation but he's got
trump derangement he's got such trump
deranged syndrome by the way so does 50
of america exactly right
except that they don't pretend that they
are the hyper rational guys that sam
harris is but but but trump truly did
break sam's brain and so i used that
explanation to to to to to at least
offer him a possible way to understand
why people who are not nazis and who
sleep with their sisters could have
voted for trump right if i prefer as i
said immigration and that's the only
attribute i look at
it will be perfectly rational for me to
choose trump over hillary i don't have
to be a nazi who sleeps with my sister
and so decision making is really an
incredible field because it allows us to
understand the cognitive processes that
people go through in making a decision
how do i choose a mutual fund how do i
choose a politician how do i choose a
mate so this is pretty much what i've
done in my academic career study
psychology and decision making so you
really are in my wheelhouse here i i
will tell you you know for uh for for me
years ago when you're going through the
conversation about you know when you're
younger all you want to think about
what's the key to success what's the key
to success hard work choosing the right
spots doing this doing that doing this
from everybody i've uh
watched win in business or they did very
well in life
the best ones were those who were better
at making decisions and processing
issues so i always wanted to talk to a
person
and then ask them how did you come to
this conclusion
because that process of how you came to
this if they're willing to tell you the
real truth because sometimes people will
just give you the lazy answer i don't
want the lazy answer give me the real
answer
how did you come to this conclusion and
if they give you the real
methodology of how kim that they came to
that conclusion you just figured out a
formula
got it so first there was that
experience with your dad that you
watched and i left a mark okay so that's
deep that's emotional that's painful got
it then
you notice that maybe you were yourself
wrong but that happened to you when
somebody treated you and judge you the
way you judge your dad and you realize
you didn't like it and he said your dad
must have not liked it as well because
that's
got it three you were hanging on to
something that your dad did years ago to
your mom
and that's between them but you took it
personally to you he never did it to you
he did it to your mom but you love your
mom
fair okay get it but that doesn't mean
he did it god so you were able to let
that go how did you let that go through
an experience you had spiritual you had
rock bottom
a girl broke your heart you lost
somebody in your life so did you need to
go through that to make that decision
yes no who knows and then eventually so
there's a certain somebody just went
there yeah
was that autobiography i was going to
say he just went boom boom boom no no
but but
but but we don't talk like that right
but we decide like that yeah so if we're
able to call a timeout and say got it
here's what we're doing with this part
this totally makes sense here's what
we're going to do next like when we
wanted to move from la to cali from
california to texas okay right i sat in
a room and i'm looking at everybody
i got merle who's about to get married i
got her husband certified but i got a
shout out to you yeah totally i get all
these guys sitting in front of me i'm
like okay how am i going to sell texas
to these guys all right so i start with
an open-ended question i'll never forget
this meeting it was in 2011.
okay and i say so guys what do you think
about texas texas
oh man i've heard such bad things about
texas really tell me what you've heard
did you know that texas this is a day
now they start saying about the texas
stuff i could never go to work in cowboy
uniform like you know you have to wear
these belts i see you think people in
texas wear buckles yeah i mean that's a
horn with the belt about like you think
on the freeway you know hey
i'm living in the first car
so then eventually gradually i took all
the concerns and i brought back stories
to address every concern and i did it
over and over and over again and then i
had to sell jen jen didn't want to move
i had to sell melva melvin didn't want
to move i had to sell family i had to
sell him plaster and eventually like
guys
we have a meeting with governor perry
and mayora frisco mayor masso
and we're going to go meet with nolan
ryan and we're going to meet with don
nelson and we're going to make a
decision whether we like texas or not
but look we may not like it let's just
see what it's like then we go to texas
we spend a whole day with them
then on the flight back i'm like so
what'd you guys think about texas
well you know it's just more impressive
than i thought
okay and then two months later guys
we're moving to texas so it sounds like
they weren't anchored on their uh it
took four years so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]